this is interesting more and more people
suffering from covid19 are reporting the
loss of taste
and smell you've probably heard about
that that's a very common side effect
yeah that's gotta suck yeah yeah well
guess what
one new company has made a product
just for those people check it out you
wore a mask
you washed your hands you practiced
social distancing
but still you got covered 19. this sucks
oh you think it sucks now try eating
something
what go ahead
well i taste my cardboard
i can't taste anything damn it lost your
sense of taste
well don't worry about it introducing
bland
blandbox
blandbox is the first meal subscription
service featuring completely flavorless
odorless colorless food units especially
made for people with covid19
how is it i can't taste anything it
looks depressing though
no depressing was that delicious slice
of pizza you ate that you couldn't taste
this has no flavor so you're not missing
anything
yeah okay with bland box food units
you're not missing
any taste or aroma and you're also not
missing out on your nutritional needs
blandbox food units are packed with
essential nutrients
what will my taste and smell come back
ah it could be months
maybe never get blandbox order today